this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by curiosity stream sign
up today and get free access to my new
logistics of d-day series on watch
nebula comm plane wings come in a huge
variety of shapes sizes and
configurations we have explored how the
AFT swept wings of a traditional
airliner and the forward swept wings of
experimental planes like the x-29 affect
the aerodynamic properties of the plane
we explained why modern jet fighters are
designed to be aerodynamically unstable
and one of my very first videos we
investigated why airliner manufacturers
like Boeing and Airbus are installing
increasingly complicated winglets at the
tips of their wings however we have
never explored in detail the theory and
practice behind wind dihedral angles
which is simply the angle the wing makes
with respect to a perfectly horizontal
line through the base of the wing and
planes throughout history have had a
huge variety of variations with this
feature from the high-mounted anhedral
wing of the av-8b harrier where the wing
angles downwards to the low mounted
dihedral wings of airliners and world
war ii era fighters and everything in
between like modern-day f-16s with low
mounted straight wings or stranger still
the gull wings of sea planes and
inverted gull wing of the f4u corsair so
what's the purpose behind all these
designs to understand this we first have
to understand the dynamic lift generated
by a wing as it rolls let's examine a
plane with dihedral winks meaning they
point upwards in straight and level
flight the lift each wing generates does
not point directly up as the lift a wing
generates is perpendicular to the
aerofoil of the wing this means the lift
of the wing points inwards at an angle
towards the fuselage this seems like a
strange design choice as only the
vertical component of lift contributes
to getting the plane off the ground and
thus the horizontal component is wasted
energy which results in additional fuel
being wasted so why do they do it by
tilting the wings upwards we gain role
stability which we explored briefly in
my white jet fighters can be to on
stable video this means that when the
plane rolls it will naturally correct
itself and return to straight and level
flight with no input from the pilots an
important safety feature this works as a
result of a plane's tendency to sideslip
when it rolls meaning the plane begins
to move sideways and downwards in the
direction of the bank this introduces a
new airflow to the wing which has both a
vertical and sideways component as a
result of the dihedral angle this flow
strikes the underside of the lower wing
with a greater angle of attack than the
higher wing and thus the lower wing now
generates more lift than the upper wing
providing a restoring force to return
the plane to straight and level flight
the exact opposite occurs with anhedral
winks where the wings pointed downwards
here when site slip occurs the upper
wing achieves more lift due to a greater
angle of attack causing the plane to
roll more high mounted wings tend to be
anhedral some sources will tell you that
this is due to the pendulum effect where
the weight of the plane itself acts as a
restoring force like how a pendulum will
naturally return to its original
position when disturbed but this is
incorrect and I nearly uploaded this
explanation on Saturday before thinking
about it a little harder and realizing
that that didn't make any sense
the actual reason high mounted wings are
roll stable is a result of how the
airflow flows around the fuselage inside
slip with high mounted wings it will be
deflected into the underside of the wing
increasing the lift on the lower wing
and thus providing a restoring moment
while a low mounted wing will have the
airflow deflected into the top of the
wing providing a moment which will
increase the roll so plane designers
will use dihedral wings on low mounted
wings to counteract the instability of
low mounted wings and use anhedral wings
to offset the stability of high mounted
wings we can see examples of anhedral
wings in planes like the av-8b Harrier
where the designers needed to use a high
mounted wing in order to utilize the
direct thrust nozzles that would
otherwise strike the top of the wing in
a low mounted wing perhaps the most
impressive example of high mounted
anhedral
is the Antonov an-225 the largest plane
in the world I could not find a
reference to back this up but I assume
they chose this wing configuration to
increase ground clearance for its sixth
turbofan engines and thus allow the
plane to have extremely short landing
gear which would reduce the material
needed for them and make loading
procedures much easier we also see
examples of low mounted wings with no
dihedral angle at all like the f16
this made the f16 slightly unstable in
role allowing for better maneuverability
the f16 was in fact one of the first
planes in existence to deliberately
introduce instability for the benefit of
energy efficient maneuvering a
technology made possible by fly-by-wire
computers angling the wings like this
does come with disadvantages one of them
is its effect on fuel economy as stated
earlier only the vertical component of
lift contributes to getting the plane
off the ground and thus the horizontal
component is wasted energy which results
in additional fuel being used but the
effect is tiny if we keep the dihedral
angle relatively small the loss in
vertical lift is proportional to the
cosine of the dihedral angle a wing with
a dihedral angle of 6 degrees like a
Boeing 737 will lose just 0.55 percent
of its vertical lift in exchange for a
roll stability the configurations
mentioned above are the most common but
there are configurations that appear in
special circumstances the f4 phantom a
fighter created before fly-by-wire
technology was mainstream was found to
be unstable during the testing phase and
thus they retrofitted a dihedral angle
to the wingtips late in the development
stage to increase roll stability this is
called a cranked dihedral one of my
favorite planes the f4u Corsair features
inverted gull wings where the wings
initially protrude out at an an Hedra
angle before sweeping back to dihedral
this wasn't for any fancy aerodynamic
reason but for a similar reason to our a
n2 55
when the f4u Corsair was being designed
the engineers had some design criteria
they had to hit namely it was required
to be capable of achieving a top speed
of 640 km/h this would require not only
a large engine to achieve the power
needed to overcome the immense drag at
this speed but enlarged propeller to
provide the thrust this created ground
clearance issues for the plane that
would require longer landing gear but a
longer landing gear would need to be
stronger heavier and would take up more
space instead the designers decided to
bring the landing gear closer to the
ground by curving the wing downwards
where it was located the gull wings of
sea planes again used them for clearance
reasons as they try to lift the wing
mounted engines clear of damaging sea
water spray these are just some examples
of how dihedral angles change for
different design criteria but from here
you should be able to look at any plane
and understand why it shows a particular
wing dihedral or anhedral angle like the
yonkers ju 87 another inverted gull wing
World War - IRRI plane flown extensively
by the Germans I will be exploring many
of these planes and other less examined
factors that influence the outcome of
World War 2 in my new logistics of d-day
series available exclusively on nebula
the streaming service my Creator friends
and I made to provide a new place to
upload our content free from the
shackles of the YouTube algorithm in my
debut episode I explored the reasons
Normandy was chosen as the final landing
location factoring in everything from
Allied fighter plane ranges to the
geology of Normandy it's a fascinating
topic that you can learn more about for
just $2.99 by signing up to curiosity
stream who are bundling our streaming
service with every sign up that uses the
link in the description with this you
will get access to thousands of
fantastic documentaries on curiosity
stream like this one titled pioneers in
aviation but also get access to all my
new videos
completely ad free and watch my new
nebula exclusive series we
nabela original series add free videos
downloadable episodes on iOS with an
Android app on the way and no algorithm
presenting you with endless click based
distractions watch nebula is the best
place to watch your favorite educational
youtubers like Wendover productions
polly matter lessons from the screenplay
Lindsay Alice Kent obento and much much
more
as always thanks for watching and thank
you to all my patreon supporters if
you'd like to see more from me the links
to my Instagram Twitter subreddit and
discord server are below